[Music]
thank you
hey everyone thank you for joining us
welcome to the uplift we've got a great
show for you today great cast of
characters as well a group of co-workers
who witness a disaster while at work
decided to rush to their neighbors also
a dog running loose on a California
freeway yay scary sight caption on
camera the story does not end there
two parents who were inspired by their
four-year-old daughter to dedicate their
lives to helping others also a father of
three who found himself homeless and the
complete strangers who came together to
give him hope all that and more coming
up on the uplift
foreign
[Music]
hey there I'm Tony decouple and this is
the uplift the show that lifts you up
for the next 30 minutes you and me as
well and we're going to begin with a
story about a group of co-workers who's
frang into action to help their
neighbors Caitlin O'Kane has their story
there aren't many people besides
firefighters who would run toward a fire
but when the employees at PS are
mechanical in Seattle saw their
neighbors building in Flames they sprung
into action because their neighbors are
dogs you can see the smoke pouring out
of the building
and uh the noise from the dogs
you know from the emergency responders
the firefighters police everybody that
was responding so there was a lot of
noise and it was chaos and you know it
was one of those situations where we
didn't know exactly what to do but we
knew we had to help smoke Rose from the
Dog Resort a Doggy Daycare in Seattle's
Lake City neighborhood Greg Hagen was
one of the employees from the HVAC
company who raced over despite the risk
working with other members of the
community to save about 60 dogs so there
was about nine of us and we all took
different roles there were some of us
that raced over there and grabbed dogs
there were some people that helped
secure the yard so that there was areas
where small dogs couldn't get back out
into the street there were employees
taking care of the dogs playing with the
dogs and at that point it was great to
see because a lot of dogs had kind of
settled in it was like
they've been given a new play park so
they were starting to have fun and run
around throughout our yard and that was
very cool but see not only did they calm
scared pups but anxious parents who came
to pick them up they had taken their dog
there that morning and seen it on the
news and were absolutely frantic and
would come up and oh my gosh do you have
our dogs you have our dog and uh to
those people I just try to be calming
hey we've got a bunch of dogs it's gonna
be okay we take them over the fence and
to see their faces once they saw their
dogs was it was very emotional there was
a couple of us that were pretty close to
breaking down in tears as well when you
see people show up and see their dog
playing in the yard and then it's safe
none of the dogs were harmed in the fire
and their neighbors have been hailed as
Heroes yeah it was a chaotic moment and
wouldn't want to go through that again
for sure but we're just glad we could
help and uh one of the really cool
things that happened was on Friday the
mayor actually came by and got to spend
some time with some of the employees and
gave us a little letter of recognition
and that that was really a nice touched
by the city of Seattle they say dogs are
Man's Best Friend these heroes are dog's
best Neighbors
exploring the Great Outdoors moving on
to our next door it can be difficult for
many people with disabilities due to the
lack of mobility of their wheelchairs
well a program in Georgia hopes to get
more people in wheelchairs out onto the
trails no matter the terrain here's Mark
Strassman with more
a walk in the woods in search of
Nature's Glory fresh air a light wintry
Breeze the sun's warmth seems so simple
but not for Mario Sanchez who's now 41.
since he was two muscular dystrophy has
been telling him no that's about to
change with this motorized all-terrain
wheelchair part of a new Georgia program
championed by Amy Copeland clean fresh
air sunlight it is a game changer it's a
life changer after a 2012 ziplining
accident gaster calf Copeland contracted
a freak flesh-eating bacterial infection
to save her life doctors amputated both
her hands her right foot and her entire
left leg someone so active no longer
able to walk she was 24. I gave myself a
nice pity party I can only do that for
so long her foundation pushed the state
for years to allow these all-terrain
wheelchairs to create moments like this
it is a freeing experience being out in
the middle of the woods with the sun on
your face and the breeze and the trees
and the birds Melanie Dunn a double
amputee and assistant director at
Copeland's Foundation says the response
to alteran Georgia has been phenomenal
just imagine that you can never walk
again and that's what it's like to be in
a wheelchair and the person that is in
this chair all of a sudden is just
Blown Away
on the edge of Georgia's Sweetwater
Creek State Park just west of Atlanta
Mario Sanchez heads up for a family
outing into the woods we go the parks
path has uneven terrain rocks branches
occasional standing water for him all
the usual deal breakers I'll put it up
to three but Sanchez suddenly is a half
mile deep in the woods immersed in its
Wonder that's so cool
it really handles good for the first
time in his life it's a blast it really
is liberating very very liberating
Sanchez found himself on a path he had
never traveled what a difference that's
cool
nicely done Mark all right coming up a
frightening sight on a California
freeway turns into a serendipitous
moment plus a group of strangers share
one goal to help a man living on the
streets of Claremont California
[Music]
thank you
now for a heartwarming video the kind
you just need to see on a day like this
taken when the Elon University women's
Lacrosse team traveled to Fairfax
Virginia for a game and it was in
Fairfax Virginia that they found
themselves in a little bit of trouble
the team bus got stuck there on a patch
of I don't know what but it was nothing
for this group of athletes who worked
together as a team and use their
strength collectively to push the bus
free
love that all right a scary sight now on
a Southern California freeway all that
captured on camera let's go to the
videotape it was a dog bolting down a
busy busy freeway and what unfolded next
is the story of heroism and Serendipity
here CBS Los Angeles is Jake Reiner with
more
from a death-defying rescue to a pretty
warming reunion
that's the dog's name pretty and her
owner Jay Segura is I'm so happy to get
her back but pretty's Journey was a near
disaster experience Segura says he left
pretty at his in-laws house in Sun
Valley for the weekend and he says she
must have escaped through a hole in the
fence here she is on Friday morning
scampering on the Northbound 5 freeway
in Arleta I just seen her look around on
TV it looked like she was looking for
her still and it's just you know it's
just it was heartbreaking as traffic
slowed down to help her one driver in a
pickup truck tried to save her but
pretty eventually picked her fighter
Glendale nurse Amber stride she just
hopped right in she just probably had a
feeling I had four other dogs stride's
Father Mark just happened to be watching
the news but had no idea it was his
daughter that scooped up the pup at the
time and I says are you kidding me I was
watching the fruit I was watching that
all happen so knowing your daughter this
all made sense to you well she's used to
saving people she she's a cardiac nurse
so she saves people all the time but now
she saved a dog Sakura tells us pretty
doesn't have a microchip but he did just
purchase a GPS caller I'm just
overwhelmed with joy and appreciation
for him and I can't wait to get her back
home after spending the weekend at
ambers and a visit from a mobile vet to
patch up pretty I just changed the
dressing today so just keep it on for
like another couple of days Amber really
bonded with pretty and pretty really
bonded with one of her dogs Poncho
definitely Bittersweet I'm glad they had
their dog back but I grew attached to
her for sure Poncho and pretty getting
along famously right now the owners say
play dates could be in the future we'll
see but as of right now they seem pretty
Inseparable in Northridge I'm Jake
Reiner KCAL news
Inseparable that's a good start I love
that follow-up coming up when their
daughter was diagnosed with a rare
genetic disease these parents did all
they could to take care of her as any
parents would and now they're focused on
taking care of others stick around
you're watching The Uplift
when two parents in Northern California
discovered their daughter had a rare
disease they started doing everything
they could to help and now they are
focusing on helping other kids just like
her here CBS San Francisco's lesla
Gooden this is four-year-old Leah who
loves to color take pictures and spend
time with her parents Rosalind and
Justin porcano she's full of energy and
by looking at her you may not know that
at five months old she was diagnosed
with Usher syndrome 1B better known as
ush1b that when I was at my doctor at
least six appointments a week standing
and then uh doctor's appointments at
least you know
seeing a specialist at least once a
month it's a genetic disorder that
causes issues with balance deafness
hearing loss and over time vision loss
for Leah she was born deaf and already
she's lost her night vision which is
retinal swelling happens
with maybe
less than half
um of all Usher syndrome patients so
it's definitely causing some blurry
vision within a year of the diagnosis
Leah's parents wanted to do all they
could to help their daughter to be able
to navigate the world independently so
they started the parent-led organization
right here in their home called save
site now after discovering there was a
need for more research for this
particular rare disease we actually
contacted the foundation finding
blindness who is the biggest
International inherited retinal disease
Foundation
we pitched this idea of like hey would
you be our fiscal sponsor we wanted you
know we want to fund through you
ashwambi research we want to maintain
our brand and our identity a safe site
now and who we are
um but you know we're happy to raise
money on your benefit if we can make
sure that funding's restricted for ush1b
research can you give it to me and I'll
go change it and changing out the
batteries in her hearing aids that are
sewn inside her pink headband it's just
another daily routine just four years
later the organization has been able to
raise nearly two million dollars right
now they're funding for research
projects with the goal creating
treatments for their daughter and others
like her
already they've been able to spread
their cause globally with other parents
they're like oh my God like even the
parents are working now where it's like
we we are incredibly thankful that
you're doing this that you've like
you've created this framework and this
structure and you know and that's always
been our goal like we never imagined
doing this alone because it is wildly
hard to do along and it takes twice as
long with this act of Love there have
been changes made for Leah to preserve
her eyesight from light dimmers around
the house to tinting every window and
while Rosalind is cutting back her time
as a personal chef both parents are
spending late hours
trying to connect with more people
willing to help on those hard days they
say Leah is what keeps them going
pretty good reason to keep going all
right coming up meet the man who found
himself living on the street and the
strangers who he says saved his life
I think he just saved my life because
you probably did so much changed in your
life just in those three weeks you were
with them it's only because of one thing
they really do care
Reverend Jesse Smith
she really cares my friend Dr Dave
NASCAR really cares why don't we end
this with me giving you a hug why not
okay
to our final story now David begno
introduces us to a father of three who
found himself homeless in Southern
California and he felt like people
treated him as though he didn't matter
but a group of strangers recently came
together to show him he does
I didn't want to do this story
and have you look like a fish in a
fishbowl that we were just looking at
okay
and I appreciate that because
respect
is a good starting point
meet Cashman Cashman Whiteley you have
had an incredible amount
of kindness shown your way here lately I
sure have and I am grateful for every
bit of it Whiteley has no home
but for the past few weeks he's been
sleeping here at the home of Carmen
Flores and her partner Tatiana Guerrero
they had seen him on the street looking
really sick and sleeping in front of a
church on a cement cold slab and the
church didn't open its doors I was like
okay if our institutions aren't doing it
then we have to do something as a Young
Man Whiteley traveled America working
carnivals yeah I see your peanut butter
money he says was always tight and after
a divorce the life of this father of
three spiraled in 2000 he landed in
Southern California didn't have money to
run a place to live we didn't know
you know a way to get started
so I simply wound up on the sidewalk
could you find a job no after 10 years
with the carnival I had no verifiable
job references
I have no dress
and at the time no phone number no the
employers got they had their standards
and I'm below it
I have been told go away no you can't
have a job application because you're
homeless
and how does that feel cash
actually if I hear it one more time I'm
going to melt down because it's wrong
because if I'm actually a human being I
should have the same chances as
everybody else
the 59 year old avoids homeless shelters
I have ADHD attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder I am not accepted
by other homeless people I don't drink I
don't use drugs
I'm Different in the Earth
this is the story about how a group of
people in Claremont California who did
not know each other stepped up to help
him and in the process they saved his
life starting with Flores and Guerrero
who housed him and fed him Jesus left us
this Sacrament Jesse Smith is a part of
that group too
she is pastor of Saint Ambrose Episcopal
Church where Whiteley showers twice a
week and attends services
Pastor Smith who along with her husband
has taken Whiteley to multiple doctors
appointments says he gets offended when
people don't treat him as if he matters
I saw it over and over going to the
emergency rooms with him
calling the paramedics having the police
called him on him here or there or
wherever
he's not seen it as a human he was seen
as a nuisance Whiteley had been ignoring
a growth on the left side of his face
until the pain became unbearable it was
so bad that I I just screamed
uncontrollably I mean literally
I told my lungs and people would call
the police and the idea was get rid of
him he would take me to the clinic the
clinic would send me to a dermatologist
the dermatologist would just say well
just just put this cream on it or
take these antibiotics which weren't
working
and then I'd be screaming again
this went on for a year Dr David nasca
is a retired pathologist who met
Whiteley on the street he called some of
those agencies that were giving him the
runaround it kept calling and
right it eventually threatening and what
makes you emotional
well seeing somebody suffer like that in
front of everybody and nobody was taking
any initiative nobody cared about him he
tried to get something done
now for that I can say
he is trying to be a good friend
the diagnosis was skin cancer he wanted
immunotherapy but his Medicaid insurance
plan didn't cover that so that's when
counselors at City of Hope a
comprehensive cancer center gave him
just that hope they helped him to change
his insurance so that he would qualify
for the care he wanted
Flores and Guerrero who both work in the
healthcare industry went with him to
advocate for him this is much better
that immunotherapy is working wonders
how do you feel well I feel a lot better
than I did three weeks ago
three weeks ago I feel like I was dying
and I probably was if you ask him how he
feels about Flores and Guerrero I think
they saved my life because he probably
did so much changed in your life just in
those three weeks you were with them
it's only because of one thing
they really do care
Reverend Jesse Smith
she really cares my friend Dr Dave neska
really cares why don't we end this with
me giving you a hug why not okay
with people like these in my life
I've got a rain on my feet I could
actually see a brighter much brighter
future it's in good shape oh you better
believe it only has 82 000 miles on it
well that future got even brighter back
in January Flores and Guerrero took him
to look at a vehicle and he liked it we
asked that it be something that helped
him in his journey moving forward an
anonymous donor gave Pastor Smith the
money for Whiteley to buy it in the name
of the
the very next day some members of the
congregation were there when it was
blessed how much money do you have now I
got about 20 yards and three quarters of
tank yes
not too bad
where are you sleeping
I'm sleeping back into the car right now
you know it's because I'm still in
transition phase
right now he is convinced that better
days are ahead for him
and it is partly because of those people
who showed him that he matters a month
ago was like you know will somebody just
heard him pull the plug on me and just
get it over with
you because I was just exhausted I can
see myself getting better now yeah I can
see myself getting back to doing some
type of meaningful work
you know
that I find very helpful David bagno CBS
News
[Music]
speaking of meaningful Network David
Beckner does it and that is our show I
hope it was meaningful to you hope it
brightened your day hope it lifted you
up if it didn't re-runs are free it's
true I'm gonna go find some good news
[Music]